libertarians are actually in personality
very much like liberals not like
conservatives very much like liberals
but just lower in compassion and just
when I was in my 20s I briefly wanted to
be a comedian and perform in places like
this but I didn't have the guts and now
this is such a cool venue and I know
you're all going to laugh at my jokes
and I can see from the smiles on your
face they're a positive audience and I
actually don't have to risk going out
making a fool of myself actually get to
speak about stuff that I know something
about and then if I forget what I'm
going to say I just pretend that that's
the end of my talk and I go to
discussion with John so this is very
exciting and very safe and I hope it'll
be fun it may also trigger some other
emotions so let's go I'm going to start
with a little quiz for you let's figure
out what we've got here in the room I'm
going to figure out I want to take your
moral temperature and figure out whether
you guys support moral position A or B
I'll read you four quotes and you just
see which one's you endorse here's the
first one for moral position a here's a
quote from it's a quote from philosopher
writing about pederasty and homosexual
relations more generally quote I have
been tormenting myself for years to find
a possible to find if possible a
sufficient ground for treating these ads
with the severity with which they are
treated at this time by all European
nations but upon the principle of
utility I can find none he then
concludes that all these sexual
perversions that were punished by death
and dismemberment should be legalized
permitted that there's nothing wrong
with them that's quote a raise your hand
if you sort of resident you think that
yeah that makes sense that sort of fits
with your morality please raise your
hand now okay and raise again if you
disagree with it okay all right now
here's the first quote for position B
it's from probably the best-selling book
of
the best the best song book of recent
times do you not know that your body is
a temple of the Holy Spirit within you
which you have from God and that you are
not your own therefore glorify God in
your body okay raise your hand if that
is expresses your morality you'll agree
with that generally okay
and raise your hand if you don't okay so
that's from from Corinthians the first
quotes from Jeremy Bentham alright now
we'll just do two more and then we'll
get a sense of who's where here's the
second preposition a questions of
morality are questions about happiness
and suffering this is why you and I do
not have obligations towards rocks to
the degree that our actions can affect
the experience of other creatures
positively or negatively questions of
morality apply raise your hand if you
agree with that if that basically fits
with your morality okay most of you
three and if you don't okay alright
here's the last quote for position B we
are repelled by the prospect of cloning
human beings not because of the
strangeness or novelty of the
undertaking but because we into it and
feel immediately and without argument
the violation of things that we
rightfully hold dear repugnance here as
elsewhere revolts against the excesses
of human willfulness warning us not to
not to transgress what is unspeakably
profound indeed in this age in which
everything is held to be permissible so
long as it is freely done in which are
given human nature no longer commands
respect in which our bodies are regarded
as mere instruments of our autonomous
rational wills repugnance may be the
only voice left it speaks up to defend
the central core of our humanity shallow
are the souls that have forgotten how to
shutter it raise your hand if you agree
with that if that's your morality okay
so I think we have a pretty clear sense
that position a win so position eight
was Bentham and that last quote before
it was Sam Harris so raise your hand if
you generally endorse position a things
aren't wrong if they don't hurt people
it said raise your hand high okay and
raise your head of people endorse
position B that's the bible and leon
kass raise your hand what half okay
Julian what was that what was like
action I predicted it'd be 90% bentham
10% cast but I guess I was wrong it's
like 95% bentham and then a half will be
whatever so now these two positions are
up you can think of them really as a
dimension of social cognition I call it
the Bentham caste dimension
it runs from Jeremy Bentham and perfect
utilitarianism on one side to leon kass
the sort of conservative philosopher who
was the head of bush's bioethics panel
on the other and people fall along this
distribution and we'll talk about that
distribution but this is what I would
call not a representative sample of
America okay now when I say it's a
dimension of social cognition think of
it this way our brains evolved to
perceive physical space in three
dimensions it's not something we had to
learn from our families like all animals
you know a horse is born and all the day
it's born it can walk around doesn't
bump into things so our brains process
space in three dimensions we get that
intuitively in the same way our minds
process social space in three dimensions
the first dimension is Chloe is a
horizontal dimension of closeness or
solidarity is what sociologists call it
all over the world people make
distinctions between those who are close
and far away your family as close
strangers are far your friends are close
your enemies are far so we just think
about people are they close to me or far
from it it's you know society will
affect how you use that but that is is
deep in an aid that you find in every
culture then there's a vertical
dimension of hierarchy people have a
sense of who's above and below now there
are a Galit Aryan cultures that actively
suppress it but it's there they have to
actively suppress it culture again will
matter it can play it up or down but
human minds all over the world perceive
this vertical dimension if you've ever
studied French or Spanish or any Romance
language you know that they have to go
through these contortions to recognize
those two dimensions and you use two
versus vous to mark both closeness on
the horizontal dimension and being at
your level or below on the vertical
dimension so those two dimensions must
be marked in English you think our
language doesn't do it but our minds do
it and that forces us to find a
substitute so that awkwardness of do you
address somebody by
stur smith or do you call them Bob
whatever the the rules for when we do
that they follow exactly the social
rules in France and Spain and other
places for switching from - to vote so
it's not just in our languages excuse me
the in doubt oh there you go so the it
so English used to do it it lost it but
it's retained it in the form of mister
or title last name so those two
dimensions are clear and simple everyone
understands those I've been studying
morality for about 25 years now and I
got interested in these aspects of
morality that nobody was studying the
aspects of morality when you read the
Bible you read ethnographies of other
cultures and all over the world it's not
just about stealing and killing an
honesty morality is often about
menstruation and food and sex and who
you're having sex with and how you
handle corpses and I thought this was
very strange and nobody in psychology
was talking about this so I was reading
a lot of anthropology and I did I spent
some few months in India of doing
interviews doing some fieldwork there
and the conclusion I came to is that all
over the world it's actually the
psychology is so similar it's a kind of
a vertical dimension of divinity now
here I've already given you a vertical
dimension so you've got to go to three
dimensions you know x axis y axis and
then a z axis coming out of the wall
let's say so imagine social space is a
three dimensional space and this third
dimension is divinity in many cultures
the idea is that there's God is at the
top the devil or demons are at the
bottom humans are in the middle some
humans are higher than others not in
hierarchy but in virtue purity sanctity
closeness to God the whole Catholic
architecture of saints and sainthood is
very similar to what you find in
Hinduism with levels of purity and
reincarnation so it's three dimensions
of social space and there's huge
variation in whether you perceive this
third dimension and my guess is that
many of the people in this room largely
don't or at least they minimize it this
third dimension is the absolute key to
understanding why sex is such a big deal
to most of the world why they more or
less all these things that don't hurt
anybody so let me just tell you a little
bit about this dimension if you
understand it then you'll understand so
much of the culture war stuff you know
I've heard some
people over the last five or ten years
say I just don't understand why they
care about gay marriage I can't I can't
even get it like are they crazy it makes
no sense if you ever find yourself
thinking of that probably it's because
it's it's a moral issue that that is a
raid along this vertical dimension of
divinity and you're not seeing that I'll
just say a little bit about that and
where it comes from and then I will give
you one final test to see if you're many
we're really zero or maybe you're like 1
on a scale of 0 to 10 I'll see if I can
move you up a little bit so why do we
have this
well actually Baba gave a great
introduction to it we humans have a lot
of social evolution we are ultra social
creatures we live in groups very tight
groups when we came down when our
ancestors came down out of the trees
lived on the ground in very dense groups
suddenly parasites and exchanging
microbes is much more serious than when
you live in small groups that are
largely arboreal then we begin also snot
we didn't go to hunter gathering early
we first went to scavenging we actually
ate meat off of carcasses which is very
disease ridden so we're exposing
ourselves to vast numbers of new toxins
but as our diet is improving where our
brains are getting bigger we have the
capacity to keep track of things that no
other animal can keep track of like the
history of something what it touched
before you got it so the emotion of
disgust it emerges as this uniquely
human emotion that guards our mouths it
think of disgust as a guardian of the
mouth like a sentinel there at your
mouth and if you when I was studying
disgust we were working with a Japanese
guy he brought in cockroaches a knockout
prism he brought in honey covered
grasshoppers from Japan and I was um you
know I was a young disgust researcher
and I said okay I'm going to eat one
I've been working with my adviser Paul
Rosen we were going to eat eat one and I
made my hand go out I made my hand pick
one up and I made my hand bring it and
as soon as got there I gagged it was
like there was a sentinel there that I
couldn't control that prevented me from
doing it uh I then took my other eyes I
just like and once I got it past my lips
it was falling but this is the border
right there that's the border and so
disgust guards that border right there
so it's adaptive but we become more
cultural and creative creatures and as
we start creating moral orders where we
out of all these other emotions and
systems that we have and so disgust
expands to be not just a guarding at the
mouth but a guarding of the body more
generally and of course sex is the other
big place where we're putting things
into our bodies we're exposing ourselves
to vast numbers of microbes and bacteria
so disgust expands regarding of the
mouth to being a garden of the body more
generally and then from there it's just
ready-made to become a guardian of the
social and moral order because anger
makes us want to punish or kill or or
use force disgust makes us want to close
off and separate and there are many
social problems which that's appropriate
when people have bad ideas communism you
know ideas that are treated as threats
we use discussed and we're afraid that
they're going to contaminate our
children totally focus on our children
so many societies every society I've
studied whatever emotional words they
use to describe cockroaches and dirty
stuff they also begin to use that to
describe moral violations that involve
don't involve the body so we're creative
symbolic species and we begin to use
disgust to structure our moral worlds
and this is the case for all of human
history until really the 20th century
begins to fade out a little bit I
collect I have a whole collection of sex
manuals not for personal edification but
for scholarly purposes I assure you and
there are all these advice books from a
hundred years ago 250 years ago you know
advice to young men about to get married
because of course they're assumed to
know nothing about sex I've actually are
there other some of those books here in
the museum there must be a section of
books on sex and the Victorian era is
really interesting turn to the section
on masturbation and what you'll always
find up until the 1920s is it's you know
all this language of degradation and and
impurity and pollution and then the 20s
a hygienic view begins to come in we get
mass market consumerism we get rising
wealth we get rising individualism so
the world that we live in is is the
first of its be called the first fully
decentralized world ever devised by
human beings modern Western wealthy
educated people live in a world which
disgust plays a much lower role than it
does throughout human history and across
cultures so that's sort of the
biological and cultural history of how
we got to the
point where we could have a Museum of
sax I mean that was not really
conceivable I would imagine until fairly
until fairly recently now I just want to
briefly say a little bit more about this
this trait this both disgust sensitivity
and then the tendency to use that to
structure your morality it varies a lot
by individuals like every trait some
people are high on it some are low and
my my recent my colleagues and I and
other researchers have done research to
measure disgust sensitivity and what we
find is that people who are low on it
tend to be attracted to liberalism or
libertarianism as Baba was saying people
are high on it tend to be conservative
also if you disgust people or you
activate ideas of disgust they get more
conservative and they get more
homophobic so there's a clearly a link
between your disgust sensitivity and
your moral judgment about culture war
issues we've shown that experimentally
and correlational Lee now political
groups differ quite a lot on this
libertarians and libertarians are of
course the sort of have forgotten I mean
you guys have a right to be annoyed you
know on all these surveys you know where
were you on a 1 to 7 scale of liberal to
conserve no I'm not I'm not on the scale
what we found what my group is found is
that libertarians are actually in
personality very much like liberals not
like conservatives very much like
liberals but just lower in compassion
and just more rational you guys
libertarians are the smartest most
logical least emotional across all
emotions and so there's there's a so
there's a sort of a general personality
similarity which is why we all hang out
together liberals and libertarians are
always hanging out together but they end
up often voting differently because they
have different views about social policy
but they're all very low and discussed
actually libertarians are even lower
than liberals they were the lowest on
disgust sensitivity it varies this trait
varies across cultures as I was saying I
did some work in India where it's really
woven into the laws and the social
fabric and it and it varies across
historical eras so once you begin to see
this that it's we sort of judge people
or not maybe not people here in this
room but most people judge people based
on what they do with their bodies
how saintly or godlike they are versus
how animal integrator to debase they are
now you can hoping to give you this
tools that now you go out in the world
and you look at other people almost like
an anthem you know like a you know like
a zoologist saying oh now that I
understand that they have the extent
clans that other animals don't have I
see why those conservatives are
believing this or that with it so and
it's not just conservatives liberals
also have this to some extent it's
really libertarians for the lowest on
this again it's part of being the most
rational just straightforward logical
not perceiving magical essences the way
that most people do so before we turn
this over to first to John and then to
all of you I just want to end with a
little sort of a harder test to pass
let's just see if you guys really are
all Benthamite s--
I'm going to ask you a series of
questions and I want you to vote by the
Alaska after we each question you can
either say yes for totally okay a
morally ambivalent or morally wrong okay
so let's start here's the okay birth
control that prevents conception raise
your hand if people that's totally okay
perfectly okay raise your hand you're
morally ambivalent and raise your
everything is wrong okay so everyone
agrees on that all right now move up the
scale a chemical abortion a chemical
abortion you know buy the pill
one week after conception so it's a
blastocyst there's no nervous system so
a woman takes the takes the
morning-after or ru-486 so a chemical
abortion a week after conception raise
your hand if it's perfectly okay okay
morally ambivalent raise your hand for
morally ambivalent and raise you have
you think that's morally wrong okay so
we're getting a few people beginning to
peel off on that next surgical abortion
in month six now let's assume for the
sake of argument that there's conclusive
proof that at that age the nervous
system while it is largely in place
assume there's conclusive proof that
there's no sensation just assume that
for the sake of this question abortion
at six months when it looks like a
little infant but you can be confident
that it won't feel any pain raise your
hand if you think that's perfectly okay
or more
morley okay raise your hand okay raise
your hand if you're ambivalent about it
in most of you and raise your hand if
you think it's morally wrong okay so now
we're shifting over but according to
Bentham upstraight meant that my
calculation if you accept that there's
no suffering and that the person who
chooses to do these things is going to
have a much better life they chose this
after a long decision process they are
making a decision for themselves
so already we see that most of you are
not actually Benthamite something about
this is already peeling you off and I
suspect it's the leon kass thing that it
just feels creepy wrong degraded even
though your cerebrally you know that
there is no suffering
all right well viability doesn't mean
the same ok viability is an issue that
could be an issue certainly but but if
we assume that there's no pain or
suffering that's really what Bentham is
all about okay all right so now hear it
no I I know I would have done different
is that's why I didn't ask that okay
okay so I and now you'll see why I asked
it all right so here's the last one
now I'm pretty good at making up
disgusting horrible stories but this one
is much much worse than then I could
ever have imagined and it's something
apparent that philosophers talk about
it's like one of their standard cases
it's it's not the trolley problem it's
something a little more involved so
here's a hypothetical story a very
wealthy man wants to have sex with young
girls but he's a he's a but he's a
utilitarian and he would never dream of
causing suffering causing causing harm
causing humiliation so he would never
dream of seducing a young girl so what
he does he buys human eggs on the open
market he has the mixed with his own
sperm in a lab he pays he pays a lot for
the eggs pays a lot for the lab
everyone's making money this is great he
pays a woman a lot of money to be a to
be a from a Benthamite point of view he
pays a woman to be the carrier the
surrogate mother at at five months of
gestation he has a special surgeon come
in perform an operation that severs the
brainstem above the
the middle so that the child would be
born to cerebrate in other words no
sensation no cognition no consciousness
it will basically be a human body oh by
the way he paid to have sex selection so
he knows it's gonna be a female embryo
you see where this is going so the child
is born he has the choice a is to have
the child's body you know
supported and then when it reaches the
age of 13 or 14 he starts having sex
with it as often as he likes now if
you're a Benthamite and well I didn't
make this I should watch out here we are
but in this building and with this crowd
this really could give some people some
ideas so my question is raise your hand
if you think this is morally okay okay
raise your okay raise your hand if you
are morally ambivalent okay and raise
even if you think this is morally wrong
okay so I've at least established that
you guys that even though all of you
went with position a to Benthamite
position yeah well how could it be wrong
if it feels so right we're asking about
what you think about this guy and his
story he's okay now you talk a little
bit more about you two what
distinguishes libertarians because you
have probably the greatest database on
the libertarian personality you've taken
you've done all these surveys of people
and in libertarians you lo and discuss
how else do they differ and how do they
differ from liberals when it comes to
disgust okay this is this which again
let's see if we get that on so I co run
a website called your morals or we've
had about 300,000 people take service at
the website unlike a Gallup and
everybody else we don't force people to
say where they are in a 1 to 7 scale of
left-right we allow them to pick not any
of them but libertarian and we have full
personality batteries not just a single
item attitude measure and I think the
most interesting difference the way to
summarize really all the rest of the
other difference is is that there are
these two they're these two personality
traits that Simon baron-cohen he's an
autism researcher but don't don't get
upset yet he says that the
the difference between men and women is
men are men's prenatal testosterone
changes your brain so we all start off
in utero to be girls and then if there's
a y chromosome is a little bit of
testosterone that changes a bunch of
aspects of the brain one of them is it
makes the brain a little bit more prone
to systemising that is thinking about
systems and modeling them and a little
less prone to empathizing so this is the
difference that sort of the master
variable difference between male and
female and also between masculine and
feminine men and Matthew feminine women
and what Baron Cohen says is that when
people get higher on systemising and
lower really low and empathizing if you
go for enough that is what he calls
autism now systemising is a great
strength it's there's nothing bad about
it at all and what we found we have we
took some of Baron Cohen's measure and
we gave it to people and we found is
that libertarian so first we find his
sex differences just as he says
libertarians are by far the highest on
systemising and by far the lowest on
empathizing and that's even true within
sex that you just look at women let's
say women who become the Rotarians are
higher on systemising and lower in
empathizing than women who don't and
liberals and conservatives aren't
actually that different on these so this
explains the great strengths of
libertarians and why they do so well in
academics why they do so well who think
tanks they're very theoretical logical
rational people we also have some logic
problems they solve them better than
anyone else so it's a strength but it
makes it harder you know empathizing
means the ability to read the emotions
and feelings of other people and
anticipate what they're going to do and
I presented these results at the Cato
Institute and some people thought that
you know they were very offended but
people said they were know that sighs
yes that's it that's exactly what yeah
that's cool yeah yeah okay Jerry Oh ex
I'm sorry we're not either oh well okay
go ahead
if your questionnaire which I still need
to take some contracts a self-selected
segment of the deterrence where there
are different kinds of the majorities
there are those so-called deontological
which really care about nothing except
stay the hell out of my face but there
are many others I think most of those
that are associated with think tanks
like your friend Ron Bailey who became
libertarians only because they were very
compassionate about human well-being and
Ron initially was lefty and he went to
work for government to help do good for
the world
he was smart enough to figure out that's
not a very effective way but he's driven
by compassion and my a mcdowell evidence
well it's certainly true that
libertarians look at social policy
positions and they say my god the
liberal view is is causing so much
damage and here's a way to do it much
better and they are upset that bad
policies are put into place by quote
bleeding-heart liberals people so
motivated by compassion that they can't
look at the effects of their actions as
for whether Ron's true motive was
compassion that is was he just going
about his business and he just kept
feeling such pain such horrible internal
pain when he saw their suffering and my
god the Liberals aren't helping what
else is there Oh libertarianism if
that's really the causal path and I
would grant that you're right my guess
though is that libertarians because they
are on average against is it sort of
averages there's lots of variations so
your mileage may vary but my sense is
that they more come to see this
intellectually and then they realize oh
my god these policies are actually much
better at helping people talking about
discuss something that the people in
this room have a hard time with what
uses are there of that feel and also do
either you have the advice for how you
know should libertarians be trying to to
figure out these discuss feelings more
to be able to understand yeah okay well
so first from just from a strategic
perspective if libertarians you know
it's funny I mean so many people will
endorse the libertarian idea
if you ask them whether they're socially
liberal but fiscally conservative like
most young people say that yet there's
never a libertarian party and
politically they're not as effective as
they could be so it might be that
learning to empathize better and assume
a virtue if you have it not for use
almost can change the stamp of nature
that might be strategically an effective
way to be able to talk to people who are
not disposition libertarian and get them
to actually be involved in libertarian
projects in a less Machiavellian vain
just thinking about does this third
dimension actually do anything for us or
is it just some ancient some atavism
that we might as well just ditch to some
extent we do need to either ditch it or
at least tone it down because it makes
us believe things like for example
miscegenation laws a lot of disgust is
just keeping things separate the kosher
laws I mean you know you should not mix
two different kinds of fiber I mean
that's you know it's just just like it's
this it's this purity and purification
idea this Georgian pollution idea just
taken to such an extreme so you know the
idea that you shouldn't let people of
different races have sex I mean we got
to get rid of all that stuff and we did
and it was greeted by the same sort of
disgust you know in the South but they
got over it and gay marriage it's
exactly the same thing and thank God
it's really working well that so what I
think is happening with gay marriage
it's not I get this debate from
philosophers a lot who say well isn't it
that philosophers made the arguments and
ultimately reason one and I think no I
don't think it's the reasons I think
it's will and grace
it's when people get used to things you
know you see it it's not it's not a
taboo it's not it's not strange so that
you lose the disgust so to a large
extent yes we must tone it down the
question I'm interested in is whether we
should totally get rid of it have no
role for repugnance and disgust in our
law and our social policy or whether
it's real for a little bit of it and
when I listen to Leon Kass I've seen him
give a number of talks and when I listen
to him and you know he's a great writer
and he's
he's saying something that seemed noble
and uplifting and I think he's right in
general and then you put up that concern
about you know oh can't we just knit
lead everything to our pleasure you put
it up against any actual policy like say
in vitro fertilization which he was
against and then it because he thought
it would dehumanize our relation to our
children well then it turns out people
did it it makes no difference you love
your children just the same his great
his his children had several IVF
pregnancies and he changed his mind too
so on specific issues where there are
people who are really clearly victims of
these policies then yeah I think we need
to try to ditch them and it seems we can
now should we end the the laws against
creating a baby and having sex with your
own child and you know I'm Justice
Scalia in in one of it whatever the
crucial his dissent his dissent and what
was the key case was Lawrence vs Texas
right so his dissent he said well if we
if we allow you know homosexual what's
next incest best reality to which I
would say since five percent of people
are gay that's a lot of people and we
really need to try to you know try to do
something about this the number of
people who can't live a full and decent
life unless they have sex with a sheep
and it's not very many people I'm
content if it does some good to have a
sense that there are public there's some
morals we share and there are a few
people out there who can't be happy I'm
willing to let them be unhappy but it's
difficult to draw these distinctions and
it causes that I mean our country was
founded on the idea that there were
different religions in Europe and a lot
of that is based on some of this sort of
discussed tribal they're sort of primal
emotions and we come up with these
justifications and so the founding
fathers said look we're just not going
to a distinguish between religions when
I couldn't say one is better than the
other
now the libertarian position on so many
of these issues about sex and gay marry
with things is that the government you
shouldn't try to start distinguishing on
these discuss things that that society
may do it and if people are repulsed by
things they'll you know that'll be
shunned it'll be unpopular but the
government's not very good in making
these distinctions and making
the stem cells okay right as a practical
matter I think that is one of the great
libertarian insights that the
philosophers might say oh well you know
there should be so the policy we know
there should be some you know central
response but that in practice the
history often will work out badly now
one of the great things about America I
think is the federal system and the fact
that very little is supposed to be
decided at the federal level marriage
policies those shouldn't be federal
abortion policies those shouldn't be
federal those should generally be at the
state level so if you're talk about
federal government yeah I think you need
to really make an argument for the
federal government take on something and
in general should stay out of all these
issues including marriage I think but
but if a state so I guess the missing
piece here the missing piece of this
discussion is is I think the ideas of
emile durkheim which have been really
influential on me Durkheim wrote this
one of his most famous books his book
called suicide in which he analyzed the
suicide statistics in Europe and found
that basically the more people were
bound into a society the less they
killed themselves people were single
higher suicide rate people were married
but no children higher suicide rate than
people were married with the more you're
bound in actually even though we say we
want liberty and freedom we actually
need some constraint and libertarians
probably need less constraint than
others but they then want to make a
world that's very unconstrained and I
think a lot of people who at the other
end of this Bentham caste dimension a
lot of people would feel dizzy and
disoriented and of despairing in a world
created by libertarians one final
question before you open it up do you
have any you talked about society
becoming decent
and this this and this revulsion against
impure things is diminishing in the West
and now it says either do you have any
predictions on the future of the culture
war is the purity discussed you know
aspect of politics and is that what's
going to happen there yeah so these
sorts of of rich thick binding morality
is that that moralize food and sex and
all that that's only possible we have
little moral diversity and you have a
long period of cultural stability then
things seem to tend to thicken up
America had a very long period from
about 1914 to the 1960s with very low
immigration and there's a kind of a
consolidation around a sort of a
Protestant identity
there's some very good things that came
out of that some analysis of civility
and civility in Congress shows that it's
in part diversity you don't have a sense
of a shared moral community there's more
more strife so there are some good
things to be said about having some
shared culture now they're also very
good things we say about diversity and
immigration and that's the way we're
going clearly and the Republicans have
realized that they basically lost the
battle over these social issues and the
reason they lost the battle is that the
demographics are just taking care of it
so since the power base the Republican
Party since the 80s has been especially
white Southern Protestants and that is a
shrinking demographic and you know East
Asians and well of course Latinos could
be very good candidates they're Catholic
they're religious so they could be good
allies it's I could I could imagine
possibly the Republicans somehow luring
in Latinos and then they could revive
this but that's not likely to happen
short of that the enormous the and
growing moral diversity makes these kind
of thick rich codes increasingly
untenable and I believe that the culture
war has now shifted radically it was
especially in the 80s and 90s was over
all these social issues over sex over
capital punishment corporal punishment
spanking your kids burning the flag all
that social stuff and all of that
actually is period even burning the flag
turns out we have data people who don't
like who object to burning the flag for
free speech purposes you'd think it was
issues of group loyalty that predicted
but it's not it's actually discussed
because they they treat the flag as not
just a piece of cloth but they there's a
sacred there's a sacred essence to the
flag
since the Tea Party which has United
libertarians and social conservatives
that that unity has forced them to
downplay the social issues because
libertarians do not agree with the
social conservatives so for a variety of
reasons that Alliance plus the
increasing demographic diversity the
Republicans can't possibly revive the
this purity stuff this anti-gay stuff
it's a losing ticket it will be more
losing every year it's just one final
thing I'm going to happen from the other
side the word greens now have their own
purely obsession with organic
food and pesticides and is that is that
what purity is going to end up going uh
yeah that's a good point I've painted it
as though it's conservatives who do all
the purity stuff liberals do it too you
know but it's commonly joked that you
know conservatives are always heavily
moralizing sex and telling what you
can't do but my god just try to you know
try to order breakfast with somebody
who's on the far left I mean that's yeah
oh you know yeah how do they treat the
workers was it Fairtrade styrofoam I
mean everything it's you know so yeah